foreign
is with us in Long Island New York hi
Rommel how are you
hey Dave and John how are you better
than we deserve sir how can we help
nice
um all right I'm a long time listener
first time caller
um I mean I'm just so far into debt and
I'm I'm scared and I don't know which
way to go with it and it's like uh you
know every time I get paid it's like I'm
on a vocal so I just go round and round
and nothing's nothing's getting done
and I'm just way over my head with
everything
how much do you owe man
um between credit cards and my stupid
carpet my stupid car loan um I'm at 45
000. okay what do you make
um I make uh
about thirty three dollars an hour
so I bring uh before taxes about 1300
but I bring home after taxes around nine
nine seventy a week are you married um I
get yes I am married four kids my wife's
a stay-at-home mom okay cool and um what
do you owe on the car in particular
at all 11 11 8 on it okay
so the credit cards are uh you didn't
like take a big trip or celebrate
something this is just life has happened
with this chaos and it ended up on the
credit card because you couldn't pay it
all exactly yeah that's normal multiple
credit cards that's normal that fits
that fits with what you were describing
a while ago the sense of being a rat and
a wheel so here's the thing if you and
your wife were to sit down
today in front of John and I and we were
just sitting there at our kitchen table
and all four of us talking
would we see two people that are
sick and tired of being sick and tired
are you ready to
go through the pain of change
because the pain of the current
situation sucks enough
I'm actually absolutely on board where
you know is she you know so so yeah 100
percent
okay
because that's a big deal I mean if you
can't because some people like the pain
of the chaos more than they like the
pain of change because changing is a
pain in the butt yeah because you're
getting ready to do some uncomfortable
stuff to break this cycle and you got to
be ready for that
yes what do you do for a living
I work on a school bus I'm a mechanic
okay
uh how old are your kids
um my oldest is 16 my son is 10 my
daughter's eight and my youngest is uh
five
okay
so here's the thing
um
no more eating out
no
and I think that's how big big issue oh
it is sure it is your wife is a
stay-at-home mom she now by God Cooks
yep all right that's her job she's a
home economist it's her part in this uh
and and when you get home uh put the
kids to bed and turn off the television
okay and we're going to start a budget
tonight and the two of you are going to
start telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went
okay
because it's a where are you where
you're sitting emotionally is a helpless
hopeless feeling it feels stuck and out
of control
yep and you know I had it when last week
I told my wife you know I'm worth more
dead than alive because I did take one
thing from your lesson we both got uh
turned life insurance good what lesson
is that you went through Financial Peace
University no no just you know from here
from the from the talk shows
okay
I got to tell you that that was a a
stupid thing to say because it's not
true
you're not worth more dead than alive
you might be worth more money at this
instant but not more money over the
scope of your life you're earning power
through the scope of your life much
exceeds that and the uh economic and
actual arithmetic value to your children
not to mention
the actual fatherhood to your children
but the actual math of what it does to
your family far exceeds that life
insurance so you're you're very valuable
to your family sir
okay thank you I needed that yeah and
and that that's that's not just valuable
in a spiritual sense which is true but
I'm talking about the arithmetic you are
actually worth more life mathematically
okay so and what we know the other
part's true yeah you're worth more as a
dad you're worth more as a person you're
a good guy I've enjoyed talking to you
for a few minutes here so
and you've you've got it whenever we get
wound up in to like it feels like we're
drowning right and you've got this debt
and it's hanging over you there's also
the chaos of you are for on school buses
yes yeah you're you have been caught in
that mess of a system in New York for
the last 36 48 months and it's been a
disaster yes and you have a
five-year-old all the way up to a 16
your house is a zoo right now
yep right and so everything feels like
it's coming apart at the seams I need
you to hear me say this it's not
when you have a 16 year old and a 10
year old and a five-year-old what was
the other one eight eight
dude you're just gonna have underwear in
weird places in your house and you're
just gonna have pee in weird like I
don't know how this works geometrically
how where P how it got this way in the
bathroom some of that just is and some
of that is um not going to war not
declaring Civil War on Ramel okay okay
you're a dad who's in a wild it's a
winter and there's no reason to go
outside and scream because it's snowing
it's winter so put a coat on man you
know what I mean and so you're in a wild
season what can you control right now
you can control this debt and let's get
on this plan you can control your
marriage you can control how much you
and your wife get together on the same
page and that's the beauty of getting on
this plan together yeah we're going to
put you in the Financial Peace
University and pay for it okay if I pay
for it and give it if I if I pay for it
and give it to you will you promise me
you will do every single thing we say to
do in the lesson yes sir and your wife
and my wife 100 okay let me let me one
up and you promise if you ever ever have
a thought again
I think my family would be better if I
wasn't here
you ever have that thought again do you
promise you will reach out to another
man that you trust and say I'm not doing
all right yes I will you promise yes
promise got it okay you're you're a
great guy and you're gonna be fine and
I've in 30 years I've walked with
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people just like you you're going to be
100 debt free you're going to be on a
budget you're going to have an emergency
fund of 15 or 20 000 and you and your
wife are going to have the best
communication that you've ever had in
the history of your marriage so far if
you will follow the stuff we teach you
to do I'll show you exactly how to do
every bit of that it's not costing you a
dime so it works dude it works it
changes everything when you lean into
this so you hold on we'll pick up and
get you signed up